foreign
dated alcoholics I feel like I've done a
lot of work the last couple of years I
took some time off dating and it was
like immediately the first so out of the
Potpourri of humans I picked the one
that is an alcoholic
[Music]
what's up this is John with Dr John
deloney showing why are we yelling
sorry
if you were just driving down the road
having a good morning and all of a
sudden I started yelling I'm sorry I'm
just in a great mood today and there's
just there's this new energy drink
called kill Cliff it's not new and it's
not an energy it's not like it's like
monster big tires on your truck energy
but I had some this morning and my wife
said you probably shouldn't drink that
anymore because already you're a lot and
if you add this to it
makes you a lot a lot
and
my kids suggest that just regular Lots
enough but I'm glad that you're with us
on the world's greatest mental health
and marriage and parenting show ever we
have a packed audience we don't have a
packed audience we have a few people
it's good to see everybody out there and
um if you want to be on the show give us
a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 and this is a special
episode it's a special Halloween episode
so hang with us we're gonna take a
couple calls and we're gonna do
something really cool at the end of the
show all right let's go to Marissa in
Phoenix Arizona where it's the fall but
it's probably still 150 degrees what's
up Marissa
hey Dr John how you doing good how are
you
I'm good it is still really hot here but
like
I haven't seen jacket last night and I
like made myself sweat just like feel
like it was cooling down hey you showed
them way to go I did you did I said that
thermostat
is it that's it that's like a jean
jacket is December right I mean that's
like late February is or early February
is is the the depth of winter in Arizona
is a jean jacket is that right
yeah I mean you're probably right that's
that's not wrong
all right all right so it's good to talk
to you what's up how can I help
yeah so I have
a dating question
um and I wrote down like three kind of
bullet point question things okay um so
I thought maybe if it's okay I could
just read those absolutely ask whatever
follow-up questions you think are
relevant yes and just remember the last
time I dated was like a quarter century
ago so I'll do my best is that cool this
is yeah yeah you know I think that
I am not I wasn't good at it then but
hey let's figure it out we'll figure it
out okay go for it
okay so should I be concerned about
dating someone in recovery related to
alcohol
and what are some good boundaries that
we can set up early on to protect both
of our mental health and then how can I
be supportive of their Journey
excellent very cool great question so um
tell me about this person
um so this person is pretty new in my
life and maybe it'll work out maybe it
won't but my the reason that I felt like
it was relevant or not relevant but like
worthwhile asking maybe somebody that is
a professional is
um
I think I've only dated alcoholics
um and I feel like I've done a lot of
work the last couple of years I took
some time off dating
I did a lot of work on myself I'm really
nice to myself now I feel better than I
ever have and I recently started like
dipping my toes in the dating pool again
and it was like immediately the first
like I was like that's that's insane
like I feel so much better and yet so
out of the Potpourri of humans I picked
the one that is an alcoholic so what
what if you look back in time so you've
done some work the last few years when
you look back over your life what has
dating alcoholics
brought you because it's brought it's
definitely brought you tough stuff but
I'm I'm specifically interested in what
are the things that have brought you
good
I
have come to describe
to people that I've dated as like their
personalities Sparkle a little bit
differently and
um I think that's the most Pinterest on
a pillow thing I've ever heard that's
incredible
people who struggle with addiction
Sparkle differently that sounds okay so
what does that mean
I I think you know I haven't struggled
with alcoholism or Addiction in the
traditional sense but
I think some of the like darkness that
comes with
or I guess the darkness that leads up to
choosing that as a coping mechanism
um I feel like I can relate to that or I
you know what I mean like they usually
have a dark sense of humor it's funny
um they tend to be
um maybe not the life of the party but
maybe also not not the life of the party
you know what I mean like they're very
easy to be around
um
they're they're not easy to be around
their altered self is easy to be around
yes does that make sense
and so often when you fall in love with
somebody who's a chemical addict or
struggling with addiction to chemicals
right if drugs alcohol whatever
you fall in love with
there is a space between you and them
and there's comfort in that space
and I know what I'm saying sounds
woo-woo but I'm I'm super serious you
are
um you are in love with the safety of
not having to fully integrate with
somebody else so much so that you're
willing to deal with the abuse they're
not showing up the lying the financial
infidelity all the stuff because I can
be in love with somebody and be in a
relationship with somebody and not
actually have to be connected to that
person because there's something between
us you see what I mean
I definitely think that that resonates
so did that come from your mom or your
dad
who where did the original Hurt come
from
both and then the subsequent step
parents I mean it was
yeah so you have a body that understands
relationships hurt
and you also have a part of your brain
that knows without relationships we die
and so you found it a a helpful Middle
Ground
I can be deeply in relationship with
somebody and then here's I I'm leading
you somewhere I can be deeply in
relationship with somebody and not ever
have to be all the way in because they
can't be all the way in because they
have wallpapered their lives with
alcohol or they've wallpapered a space
between me and them with you know weed
or cocaine or whatever they're using to
to hide from the world you see what I'm
saying yeah and so
laughs
then your addiction becomes and tell me
again tell me if I'm wrong your
addiction becomes taken care of
you are going to prove that you're worth
being loved
by taking care of picking up
um saying it's okay drawing boundaries
and then letting them push on them a
little bit is that fair or tell me 100
100 accurate okay
so you've done this before you are every
bit an addict as they are
yeah Pia Melody calls it Pia Melody
calls it love addiction
you're addicted to being in love but
your body can't take being in love so
you go towards somebody who's an addict
so y'all can be in love together but
you're both in love with fictionalized
versions of yourselves
and then you try to solve it until it
blows up which it inevitably will
is that fair yeah
and now you've done a bunch of work on
yourself and you're ready to plug in
then
way to go yeah okay so I think about six
weeks to find this person through like
dating apps and things like that and I
was like oh
like yeah I'm like Sober Sober though
you understand that right and I was like
oh okay so I I I actually have don't
have any concern
with like the idea of somebody being in
relationship loving marrying falling in
love with somebody in recovery not a
little bit I will say if somebody's
using actively then marriage counseling
is a waste of your time
because you're not dealing with that
person you're dealing with it with the
addiction right so if somebody's sober
man that's the time
I wonder if your hesitancy is you
haven't been with you haven't been all
in with somebody who's
actually looks you in the eye and means
it
I agree with that like I am
like I was an only child I am terrified
of actual closeness with other people
um and
I like I want to I've I've worked so
hard
to be nice to myself and I
I want to protect that at all cost right
um I don't I don't want to go blindly
into this and think like oh but this
time it's going to be different and then
it's not but but but but
your relationship can never work if
that's the way you enter into it
the challenge with relationship is or
the the devil of relationships is you
have to go all in
and when you go all in that means you
could get hurt again
but if you don't go all in
it never it never becomes what it could
be
and so you've done all this work you are
the Olympic gymnast that was almost
um going to the Olympics and then you
blew out your ACL and tore your Achilles
tendon and you spent two years in rehab
and now you are at the mats again
and they're telling you to go do your
Roundup flip-flop whatever flip flap
flippity flop things that a gymnasts do
and you're standing there remembering
not being able getting carried off the
mats because you your legs had blown out
yeah you've done all this work and here
you are and the reality is you could go
do a round off flip-flop and blow out
the other knee you could blow out the
same knee
or you can go in a gold medal
foreign
do you see what I'm saying
yes I completely agree so if you enter
into this relationship and you go for it
you're gonna have to let him know
I am practicing being in relationship
with somebody
and so I'm gonna be awkward sometimes
and I'm gonna be weird and it's about me
and it's not about you
that is your that is your entry point
into this
because you can and what I think is cool
about this is
um he'll have this he'll have the same
language as you
you were addicted to
uh alcohol I was addicted to rescuing
people
and so I'm sober too
I can't heal you I can't rescue you I
can't keep you sober what I can be is
the best girlfriend you've ever had in
your life
or that's not even true don't I strike
that from the record I I can be me
which I think is going to be the best
girlfriend ever
foreign
okay this here's what you're going to
practice clearly stating what you need
clearly stating your boundaries
understanding when you start trying to
take care of him or fix him or solve him
that that's not your job
where is that line between you know
somebody
in lots of therapy and group sessions
and all of those things and so like he's
actively working on learning
things
um so when he asks me my opinion on
stuff
where are some of those lines of this is
me trying to fix you or tell you what
you need to do for yourself versus if
you get invited
it's an invitation
okay when I see my wife walk through the
kitchen and in a certain way and I think
oh gosh she's in a bad mood
and I start looking around the house to
try to solve that bad mood
what I have done is taken her autonomy
away I've taken her personality away
I've taken her strength away and I have
made it my mission to fix her because
she's clearly broken she's not operating
efficiently right now
that's where I get myself into trouble
that's when I use the relationship I use
my wife to make me feel better about
myself
the other side of it is when I see her
walk through the kitchen I can get up
from my chair put my phone down and walk
over and get in front of her as she's
walking through and say hey you okay
and I let her answer and she said no no
I was just thinking about something else
cool I just saved myself and all of us a
whole bunch of hassle because I was
about to start trying to solve something
that wasn't even a problem or she can
say yeah I'm really struggling with I
miss my granddad who passed away last
year I missed this I I've got to have a
hard conversation with one of my
coaching clients she can speak into it
so if you are invited to give your
opinion give your opinion that doesn't
have anything to do with him that has to
do with you not thinking your opinion's
got validity to it
okay and it does
it never has before because your
opinions were a waste of time because
you're trying to keep addicts alive
and you're not doing that anymore
now your opinion's worth being your
opinion
and he might not like your opinion and
he may say I don't want to date because
your opinions are stupid
and then you go well I'm freaking
Marissa from Phoenix so that's my
opinion or let's then send me an article
and I'll read it and see if we can and
then we'll have a discussion and we'll
see what I'm saying now we're talking
about relationship back and forth give
and take I think this well I think this
now we're in an exchange we're not in a
prop Meetup so I can prop you up so I
can prop me up so I can prop you up
okay
if you find yourself trying to solve
problems without being invited in that's
when you know
okay or when you see him hurting
and you feel bad
that's a that's an alarm
okay
because you're gonna rush in and try to
make him feel better and that can never
be your job
okay does that make sense
yeah it does
you sound you sound scared
um
I'm nervous I think uh
I think I am nervous I feel like
um I'm looking for the the glaring red
flags and I I can't I can't find them so
I'm waiting for the other shoe to drop
because nobody's perfect
um
so yeah I'm nervous do you re hold on do
you realize you just contradicted
yourself okay
you really like this guy
or you like the idea of this guy
and you know nobody's perfect
and yet you're waiting for him to prove
himself not perfect
so there's no reason to wait for other
shoes to drop
they're already all scattered all over
the floor all over the house all over
the neighborhood
you're not perfect he's not perfect and
so y'all can choose to be not perfectly
perfect together
or you can choose not to be
but you have so much like physical fear
about being intimately connected with
somebody I'm not talking about sex I'm
talking about close with somebody
that you go in with so much hedging
I'm waiting for this I don't know about
this I'm worried about this well it
could be that just go
and be willing to say hey I I said
something last night I'm taking I get
take backs I get take backs I'm a
recovering addict I get take backs or
I'll be right over and then as you're
grabbing everything to run to his rescue
you stop and you text him and say
actually I'm already in my sleeping
clothes
um
let's get together for lunch tomorrow
I've got some time for lunch tomorrow
and then you're gonna feel that
maddening discomfort that you couldn't
run to the rescue you're gonna feel it
and you're going to have to practice
that feeling
and he's gonna have to practice being
uncomfortable being alone being scared
being tired being exhausted and not
trying to alcohol and not having
somebody come run to save him he's gonna
have to learn to stand up on his own two
feet and then you're all going to be
practicing these things together
does that make sense
yeah it does
are you seeing somebody still
um am I still seeing him about your ass
no I know you're still seeing him gross
I can hear it like what about um what
about you
what about uh a counselor you still
talking to somebody
uh on and off today I have it in a
couple months okay cool
so when do you have a date planned
yeah he's played pretty predictable and
reliable and chasing but not in like a
love bombing way and I feel like a dog
chasing her tail that like caught it and
I don't know what to do with it now
do you not like him
I do like him I just don't I you know I
was like oh I want somebody like this
right and then you
have like a few I've never had like a
long list of they have to have I've
never had that but like these are some
of the qualities that I want in a human
and a partner
and then like
they're like oh here I am and I'm like
oh what do I do with it now
I'll say this word over and over I want
you just to to get this tattooed on your
forearm okay in the most basic way get
like one of those arrows over it or
underneath it okay actually don't do
this
um I grew up in a home where money was
scary
like the times my dad had to go to the
grocery store knowing we didn't have any
money but he had three kids I had to eat
okay it was tough
and I uh my car I bought for a thousand
dollars and I drove it for six years and
it was like a giant roller skate it was
so teeny
um and it was gonna break at any moment
and it just kept it was a Toyota so it
kept going it kept going money has
always been then I went and got myself
in six figures worth of debt like money
has always been a source of pain
and then
my wife and I got radical we paid off
everything I don't know anybody anything
anymore
and now I work at a job Dave Ramsey's my
boss he pays me takes care of us really
well and
I'm having to practice
not being terrified every month when
bills come in
I'm having to practice
um
spending money
does that make sense
yeah because it's a terrifying it's
terrifying for me because my whole body
says this all ends right now
and
I don't think that's true
it could it could all end tomorrow no
question about it and as my friend Todd
says I don't have a meteorite plan
like if that happens if inflation goes
to 500 and we're killing our neighbors
for water okay I'll deal with that when
that happens that's not probably not
gonna happen though and so
I'm gonna practice I'm gonna pay for
something and I'm gonna feel
uncomfortable about it and I'm gonna
feel that random weird guilt for no
reason about it
and then I'm going to enjoy it
and so you are going to go on this date
and you're going to look him in the eye
and you're going to say I'm a recovering
addict too so I'm practicing as well
so if I'm awkward or weird it's about me
it's not about you
and you are all the things I put on my
list but I also have never done like
I've never been with this list before
and so we're going to be figuring this
out as we go and you're going to keep no
secrets that way you can be as light as
possible you're not carrying a bunch of
cinder blocks around with you and then
all of a sudden
this might work
or it might not
we're just practicing
because you're in recovery too and let
me tell you this Marissa
I'm so proud of the work that you've
done I'm so proud of the honesty you
have walking into this relationship
and
I'm proud of the person you're going to
become he's lucky to have you and if he
chooses elsewhere or you choose
elsewhere great
but if y'all get married I get to come
to the to the wedding okay cool deal
we'll be right back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from our sponsor from betterhelp I've
been on the giving and receiving end of
therapy for years when I was spinning
out like a decade ago with wild anxiety
I had a moment that light bulb moment
that I knew I had to do something
different I knew I had to change
something probably a lot of some things
right but I found myself without the
tools for taking the next step
when you're facing problems or
challenges in life it's way too easy to
get stuck in that anxious spiral of Doom
I've been there but when you learn how
to stop that cycle and start taking
ownership of your life that's when
you're free
and that's what therapy can help you do
it gives you the tools you need to do
the problem solving in your own life and
that's why I love better help better
help is online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist it's more affordable than
in-person therapy plus you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours if you're ready to get the tools
that you need to deal with the
curveballs life's thrown at you therapy
can help visit betterhelp.com deloney to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp.com deloni
all right we're back let's go to Bailey
in Salt Lake City Utah what's up Bailey
hey how are you I just I am Dancing On
The Ceiling Lionel Richie style what are
you doing
oh I'm just hanging out
hanging out vampire style lost boy style
so what's up
so um in the past year I have gone
through a season of some pretty
heightened anxiety and a lot of feelings
like that that I hadn't ever really
experienced before and now I feel like
I'm kind of coming out on the other side
of that and coming through some of those
things and now I feel like I have
anxiety about having anxiety
like scared congratulations you're
official
uh what what uh what was the impetus
behind the increased anxiety what
happened last year
you just put a period into that it's
like oh you're gonna be anxious and
depressed and why like good grief how
was it
um it was good and I really enjoyed my
it was a great year I really like
enjoyed my experience and I'm glad that
I am through it for sure
um but I think it definitely like
sparked just this heightened level of
all those types of feelings that I had
to deal with that I hadn't ever dealt
with before and now I'm like
scared when I start to feel like that a
little bit I feel like I'm scared to
kind of go back to that place that I was
in oh excellent okay
so do you know my background with law
with lawyers and law students
um just a little bit okay I was a dean
of students at a law school okay and I
spent five years it was transformative
for me
um
as a non-jd person someone with who's
not who's not a uh an attorney I don't
know that there's anybody else in the
country that's got more respect for law
students law faculty members and the
attorney I just think
um I love everything about it and
I also spent five years plus an
additional three years studying lawyer
mental health and whoa right
yeah you're like yes yes
so
um I'm gonna rattle things off the top
of my head here okay
um
I'm gonna make a note real quick because
uh part okay
so here's what I noticed in my students
and here's what the literature said I'm
just gonna braid it all together okay
number one the pressure of law school is
no joke
the top 15 of you will make this much
more money than the rest of the others
the top 30 of you will get these jobs
and the rest of you will be left to be
involved in a type of Hunger Games for
the rest of the jobs this group will
make two hundred thousand the rest of
you will make forty eight thousand plus
commission right it's no joke and it's
not like a
you know I'm kind of thinking they're
very clear about it right
yeah and then
you've been the smartest person in your
area in your Sphere for a long time or
at least one of the smartest that you
know and then they dump you into law
school into first year 1l class
and you look around you're like oh
everybody's a laser
yeah and even that dude over there who's
wearing like the Pantera shirts and he's
got a mohawk
turns out he missed zero questions on
the act right yeah I mean like you know
what I mean and yeah he's smoking weed
in the parking lot yet he's way smart
like the whole it it blows up every
Paradigm you have right
yeah and that's unnerving and so the
identity you built on being the smart
person the safety you felt being the
smart one is now it's gone and a lot of
people experience this when they
graduate college and they go to their
first job like oh yeah I'm a hard worker
and then you show up and you're like
everybody here is a hard worker and if
you make that sale
you take food off my plate so you don't
make that sale that's my set right now
all of a sudden you're like I don't know
it and then your body just starts
sounding the alarms Okay the third one
is you stay up you work 20 hours a day
is that fair yeah yes it's studying
studying studying studying and then the
whole uh what I don't tell me about law
school you are attending but
um is it so crowd is Socratic I mean do
they you they say read the chapter okay
awesome okay so if you don't know what
that is you're just listening to this
here's how law school Works they say
read 500 pages between now and next
class and that doesn't mean just scan
your eyeballs over it that means you're
going to chart out everything you read
all of the cases why the attorneys did
what they did why the judge said what
the judge said why the plaintiffs and
the defendants did what they did you're
going to go through all of that and then
you show up to class
and your professors at the front of the
class and he may say Bailey
tell us about case whatever and Bailey
stands up and for the next 45 minutes
it's Bailey versus the professor
why do you think that what happened
right that is and in most law classes
it's completely random right
yes yeah so you don't know if you're
gonna get shot you just go to class and
you're like I'm just going to class
going to class you on display hour go
and you're in front of all your
classmates who you want to be impressed
you want to impress you want to have
um you want to line up you know you want
to be the first I want to be this I want
to be included on their journals but
that is a recipe for anxiety if you're
not anxious when that you're possibly
sociopathic
there is one or two people that every
day they're like I hope to God that
faculty member calls on me because I'm
going to burn them to the ground and
they get called on and they stand up and
you can tell they like it
right yeah yeah there are those people
you're you're not that person most
people are not that person right those
people go on to become uh law professors
they're incredible right they love every
second of this
um and then here's the other extreme
the research tells me that
when you make partner whatever that
looks like and I'm just assuming you're
going to go to a firm okay instead of
going into public service if you make a
partner
the research tells me that you walk out
and you get a massive
bonus a massive increase in your check
you also get a massive increase in the
responsibility of the firm and the
plaintiffs and the people's lives you're
impacting and
there's this
um
terrifying feeling
that I gave up my 20s
I gave up most of my 30s
I gave up Little League games I gave up
Saturdays I gave up hikes I gave up
fishing
and it wasn't worth it
does that make sense
yeah yeah that makes a lot of sense law
school has an incredible way
of making you a different type of
thinker that's its job and I'm so
grateful for it and it has a very unique
way of pulling you apart from your why
why am I doing this
why am I trying to get on this journal
why do I want to be in the top 25
percent of my class why do I want to
work at this particular firm and they
continue to push you towards external
metrics look at the cars you can have at
the homes you can have at the money you
can have
and if that's what you're about that's
what you're about man there's people who
do it for years and years and years and
years and years I've just set at a lot
of the lawyers assistance programs
meeting I've I've met with them I've
researched them I've presented at their
conferences
true man
it's an exhausted burned out tired crew
right
yeah and I think that I you know there's
a plan that they like put you on in law
school that you're gonna graduate and
you're gonna go to a big firm and you're
gonna make a lot of money and I am kind
of
not bought into that plan and I and like
in this season of being like I want to
build a good life for myself not just a
good job for myself and so trying to
balance that all at one time is
challenging to say the least and so then
and I'm also just at Heart Like a
planner like I would have every detail
of everything planned out for the rest
of my life if I had the capability and
so I kind of feel like a lot of days I'm
just in a constant like mental battle
with myself of like I want to do this or
no I want to do this or this is what I
want to do or but I can't control this
aspect but I want to control this aspect
and
I feel like I am coming through some of
those things and learning how to handle
some of those things but then when I
start to feel like that again I almost
like Panic like I'm like oh God like I
don't want to go I don't want to go back
to what I was doing before all right so
the the devil of anxiety is that once it
it passes
that it creates new anxiety about being
anxious right you said it perfectly the
last time okay so I want you to think of
your first year of law school have you
ever been water skiing
I have not okay actually when you're in
the water and the boat goes it hit they
Hammer the boat and they start pulling
you out of the water the first hundred
yards or so you are half of your body is
underwater and half of you is above
water and you're just it's like somebody
spraying you in the face with a fire
hose yeah and then when you Crest and
get on top of the water it turns into
glass
so you just have to get through that
initial what is happening
and that's where a lot of people fall
off if you look at the number of people
who just have hookups the number the
people who start drinking too much
people who put on a lot of weight who
quit exercising it's that first year
it's trying to deal with that Onslaught
coming
so on the other side of this you're on
the other side of it now you're just
waiting to be submerged and sprayed in
the face again at will come it will come
make no mistake
walking around clinched up waiting for
it a won't make it hurt any less when it
gets you and B is just gonna ruin the
days that you're not getting sprayed in
the face
yeah that makes sense so here's the
simple word awareness
when you start to tense up thinking
about being anxious in The Future Smile
take a huge deep breath and hold it for
three to five seconds relax breathe it
out and consciously pull your shoulders
down as far as they will go
and say okay
it's gonna come some point not today
then the next day not today and what
you'll do over time is you will teach
your amygdala you will teach your brain
that you are driving
and it will know okay this is harling
this is scary this is stressful but
she's in control we don't have to go to
fight or flight
that makes sense yeah where's that next
world are going to take care of our
brain and listen
I'm always like okay sure when a1l tells
me I'm gonna do this and then this and
when I'm 33 I'm gonna do this I always
do like oh man I'm gonna hand you my
card and win this supernovas which it
will
um give me a call right your obsession
with planning is a is an anxiety
response
it's fake control it's pretend
and you think you've wrapped the world
up in your fancy planner and your apps
you haven't it just is a way to to
neutralize the anxiety
and so we're going to make a plan for
today we're going to make a plan for
this semester and we're going to hold it
Loosely we're gonna we're gonna follow
that plan to a t until that plan turns
left and we're gonna go left
and we're gonna make a new plan and
that's gonna be annoying it's gonna be
frustrating but it's not going to be
anxiety inducing because we know it's
coming
is that fair
yeah that's what we're going to practice
okay I'm gonna give you two other things
that I want you to do as a law student
okay okay make friends
regularly see them even at the expense
of studying sometimes and especially
people that are not law students
themselves
okay okay law students and lawyers
their weapon of choice is human
interaction
and when you're a boxer or an MMA
fighter you go to work you go to the gym
to practice fighting and you put on
gloves and you put in a mouthpiece and
you punch other people and then you take
your gloves off and your mouthpiece off
and you go to the grocery store and you
can't punch people at the grocery store
because you're not at work anymore
attorneys do not have
um
they don't take their gloves off they
don't take their mouth pieces out they
just go to the grocery store
and you know you are learning skills
because this is your job to defend the
the people who have no voice
you know how to eviscerate somebody how
to take somebody apart and because
that's have you already been accused at
the at the kitchen table of or
Thanksgiving dinner they're like ah
right all right that's enough yeah my
mom tells me I'm worrying yeah you know
why because you are you're like a kid
that just got a Nerf gun and you're
shooting everybody with it it's fun but
only for you and here's what happens
your circle gets smaller and smaller
because people don't want to hang out
with you as much anymore because all you
talk about is this and this and can you
believe this and have you read the whole
thing on your Apple iPhone the whole ins
like section you know what they're they
actually take you're that person and
then you only end up hanging out with
other attorneys and everyone's exhausted
and everyone's trying to one-up the
other one and so then you start meeting
at bars and then now we're down the road
see what I'm saying
that group of friends I have a good
group of friends at school but that
breeds just a lot of the anxiety and
stuff too like it's great to talk to
other people about the experience but I
also like fully believe that law school
is a very individual experience for
every person and so sometimes hearing
about everybody else is just just like
oh God yeah and if you're like well I
didn't think that class was that hard
then they look at you like oh you're one
of them and if you say oh that class was
so hard they're like I've got her nailed
to the wall right there's yeah it's you
have to have community in law school
period attorneys have to have community
at their firm in the local bar
associations you got to do that and also
you've got to have friends that are not
in that world that are just talking
about their pets and Lawn Care and
things like that you've got to have
other people and finally
I recommend to every single attorney uh
law school a law student every single
attorney in training
start talking to somebody now whether
it's a coach whether it's a counselor
somebody who is going to consciously and
with some regularity challenge you
are you still connected to why you're
doing this in the first place
where are you on your why where are you
on your purpose why are you going
through all of this hell that is law
school
because if it's for 125 000 a year it's
not worth it
if it's to become
credentialed so that you can help
anybody and you can take on the big guy
you can help the little guy you can make
the world a better place then law school
three years is nothing
because you'd walk through fire to help
people in your community
and that's why I just think I've I'm I
have such high respect for law students
and law faculty members and attorneys
because of what they are able to do for
the least of these in our communities
and yes there's morons there's morons in
every industry good grief should you
should be a part of the podcasting
industry there's morons in my house I'm
one of them so like there's morons
everywhere but I'm just so impressed I I
don't I got a couple of doc phds I don't
think I could have done law school I I
couldn't have gone to war like that
every day and so I'm so in awe of you
who do it
um
like Bailey
I want you to always remember who you're
gonna be at the other end of law school
as you enter the legal profession as you
fight for a living for other people
where can you take those gloves off take
your mouthpiece off and say whoo I'm
Bailey
let's go get something to eat talk about
dogs or pets or whatever it is we'll be
right back
Dr John deloney here hey it's pumpkin
spice latte season
just kidding it's disgusting but it is
fall it's a little cooler the sun's
going down earlier and God save us
daylight savings time is ending or
starting or whatever the time is
changing again and it can be exhausting
to adjust but make sure you're moving
your body every day getting some
sunlight and getting seven to nine hours
of good sleep each night I can't stress
enough how important this is sleep is
the Cornerstone to physical and mental
health and for me great sleep starts
with a great mattress and that's why I
love dream cloud and right now dream
cloud is running a great offer for our
listeners 599 dollars in accessories
plus an additional 250 Dollar Cash
discount that's a total of eight hundred
and forty nine dollars in accessories
and savings you'll get pillows a
mattress protector and luxury sheets so
go to dreamcloudsleep.com deloney or
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
deloni to get your new mattress to day
[Music]
what is up we're back
and if you ever wonder what it looks
like to lose control of your
professional life
I am wearing a uh Dracula Cape I feel
like Justin Bieber with this collar
popped this high
and everyone in the booth is
this looks like some of y'all look scary
man like I look over and it just looks
terrifying
there's a Halloween episode Halloween
episode is this coming out on Halloween
yes this comes out on Monday October
31st if you had just gone oh God that
would have been incredible
um so it is Halloween today so happy
Halloween everybody
um so we want to take a minute and talk
about the psychology of
horror movies
scary movies being scared
um because there's some actual real data
around it some actual real psychology
around it and uh just so happened we've
been planning this for several weeks and
it just so happened that one of my
favorite writers and podcasters names Dr
Peter attia attia he has the drive
podcast phenomenal
um it's a very very very deep dive into
how physiology Works in longevity but
it's good especially if you're a nerd
um but he wrote an article this weekend
him and uh Catherine birkenbach wrote an
article called the Paradox of horror and
so
um
I'm gonna I'm gonna go through some of
the stuff that they pull up here and
then talk about a few other ideas about
what's in the literature and the
scientific literature why we love
scaring ourselves real quick uh Ben Jen
everybody what's your favorite scary
movie of all time I have to say probably
Halloween the original but I'm a huge
fan of the new movie Black phone I've
got to see that I got it three times and
it's just amazing all right I'll see it
all right I'll check it out you've been
telling me to watch that okay Ben what
do you think I gotta say Paranormal
Activity dude like the OG the first one
that's on the very top of my list yeah
Jenna um can I just say Nightmare Before
Christmas because I don't like to be
scared well it's a cartoon but if that
scares you then no it doesn't scare me
that's why I like it or you know Edward
Scissorhands that one's pretty good too
again more of a love story like love
stories I don't like the jump scares if
it's gonna make me pee my pants I don't
want to watch it that's fair so that's
fair
you
staring at me through the the glass with
that terrifying mask on he's just a
barnyard animal he's just a like a what
is that a llama
uh yeah I scare myself looking at the
camera I also don't do scary movies
uh very good okay so I think mine mine
is
my wife tells me that like back in the
day when I used to be a Rebel Rouser my
jaw would get a particular way before I
got in a fight and then I would start
laughing I would start cracking up and
the first time I saw paranormal
Paranormal Activity the original one
I went home and I was laying in my bed
laughing like I thought it was on I
could not shake that movie that was
terrifying Blair Witch Project when it
first came out there was all that hype
around it that was intense it just kept
ratcheting up and then I have to admit
the first Scream Scream one
um if you don't know Scream one Drew
Barrymore was at the front of was the
cast and by spoiler alert
um just hit the fast forward button if
you don't want to hear it but Drew
Barrymore was the the big star at the
time huge like famous star a bunch of
big movies out and she was the first
person on the poster right and
then she's killed off in the first five
or six minutes of the movie and I
remember just being in the theater
looking at my buddy being like
what do you do what happens now I don't
know what happens now and then the whole
movie was just an unwinding of they kept
thinking like they kept leaning towards
this is who the person is this is who
the person is and it never was dude it
was awesome and then and ending I didn't
see coming it was phenomenal movie I
just remember leaving it going whoa it
was terrifying Silence of the Lambs all
those movies are terrifying all right so
here's the question that's posed um by
Dr Atia and Dr birkenbach are there any
other species on Earth that deliberately
scare ourselves do squirrels cross the
road and sit in the middle to see how
long they can wait I always wonder that
or to deer run up to wolves and like
scare them and then try to Sprint away
to see if they can make it probably not
so why do we do this is it just for
adrenaline do we do this just to amp
ourselves up Well turns out that
possibly
um it could be to improve our mental
health that sounds weird here's what the
researchers say
um this is from a study a meta-analysis
um uh Colton Scribner and Kara
Christensen note that individuals with
high anxiety report greater enjoyment of
horror than their less anxious peers
suggesting that engagement with horror
media results in outcomes namely
reduction in anxiety symptoms that tend
to reinforce this engagement in anxious
individuals sounds weird if I go scare
myself it could make me a little less
anxious so we know that the only way
through anxiety to heal it is to go
right through the middle of it the more
you run from it the more it reinforces
itself so there's something about
turning and staring it down and here's
what the authors suggest
it fully captures our attention watching
a scary movie
you getting grossed in somebody else's
life and again one of the Devils of
anxiety is it makes it about you you're
about to die you're about to get
rejected you're about to get laughed at
and when you watch a scary movie you're
you're saying to yourself they're about
to get Hatchet murdered or they're about
to get disemboweled on some cruise ship
or whatever movie you're watching I
don't know or if you're Jenna
um like Rapunzel's about to let her hair
down out of the tower I don't know what
horror movie you want but like you're
you're thinking about somebody else
right it fully engrosses you and takes
you out of yourself into somebody else's
story pretty cool
um humans are hardwired to bias their
attention towards imminent threats it's
super helpful if you're anxious when you
see somebody else's threats right
another one it gives us a sense of
control over our anxiety we have very
limited ability to change or remove most
of our day-to-day sources of anxiety
inflation job security the next possible
covet variant all that
but murders murderous clowns on the TV
all I got to do is turn the lights on
all I got to do Kelly loves clowns
um all I gotta do is turn the film off
I'm in control of this
and the worst thing that happens here is
that person gets murdered not me right
so there's this pseudo control it
provides and this is the one that's that
resonated with me it provides a safe
means of facing threats and practicing
resilience okay practice I say that all
the time it teaches me to practice it
teaches me how to oh gosh who's gonna
die who's gonna die and then that
tension is released the endorphins are
released and I'm still alive so in a
weird way my body is practicing being
terrified being under threat and
surviving that threat and then it
creates a physiology and a psychology
for living after the threat they go they
write some researchers have noted this
phenomenon they reflect the human desire
to learn about relevant threats and to
understand how dangerous the situation
might look
which and which reactions yield the best
income I mean outcomes it's like our
brains are practicing what happens if
there's an actual outbreak or our brains
are practicing what do we do if somebody
walks in our house in slow motion with a
hatchet and they start chopping
everybody up
um or if you're Jenna and it's a really
scary cartoon Tom and Jerry just get
right whatever's going on so
um unlike the real world counterparts
horror films have a definite endpoint we
can typically expect that they'll
conclude with the satisfying resolution
of the problem the threat is neutralized
and the good guys prevailed so it's a
way for us to enter into terrifying
situations
and be a part of them but not all the
way not all the way um it can also
promote social bonding here's a couple
of other ideas
um Dolph zilman
uh created a theory
um called excitation transfer Theory
um this suggests that
people love watching scary things
because their body rolls into fight or
flight and then it's excised
and then your body fills up with
endorphins you get high right so it's
like Runners High a little bit
um you get it's a it's feelings of
release relief or feelings of of
laughter feelings of oh like like it's
relief and so people watch scary movies
they endure the gross stuff
to get high on the back end
um the other one is a like I said it's a
way to experience fear Terror
um scary things and see them resolved
right see them end and then the final
one is curiosity
curiosity I hadn't thought of that
before but some people hear about
um
weird this and that they Wonder like I
don't know I've never seen somebody get
murdered this is a way to get the
pictures in your mind without actually
having to experience it because if you
experience it you may not make it out
and so those are some of the ideas
here's what I've found in my life
um I was obsessed big shocker with scary
movies it used to be when I was
um High School in college I saw every
single one all of them 100 of them I
never missed never never missed
um I had a buddy man we went to all of
them we got every one of those weird B
movies we could find we were all into
the
um the genre
and it did over time ratchet up my
anxiety I believe that's just me it's n
equals one experiment the more I filled
my head with that stuff the more I began
seeing threats everywhere or more
importantly experiencing feeling
threatening things somebody would walk
into a restaurant and I had a picture in
my head of the guy that walked in the
restaurant and just
you know pulls out a blowtorch and melts
everybody like I had that picture in my
head and it was an unreasonable picture
because we're at Burger King at 11 A.M
on a Wednesday right it's not gonna
happen but I had that picture in my head
it's kind of like our overconsumption of
media right now we think there are
Shooters everywhere and there's not
there's not but because our media like
our news feeds cannot put out a news
feed without somebody without some
murder happening if you look at it
sometimes it'll say so and so shot and
killed by so and so
and it says Milwaukee Wisconsin and I
live in Florida right they're going to
find somewhere in the country to put
some fear in front of you because that
fear it's engrossing right
um and so I found that as I walked away
from it
I just had more peace in my life that's
just my experience and here's the other
thing when I started working with the
police department
um my dad worked in homicide and I
remember as a little kid he had a
throwaway comment he said I can't leave
you to watch this stuff for
entertainment
and I remember being like Oh you're such
an old man dude what a boring old man
when I started going into people's homes
at 2 A.M and there was actual blood and
actual guts and actual screaming and
actual weeping
dude horror movies became not fun at all
like I haven't watched one in years
because I started seeing this stuff for
real and I started sitting with people
for real and so in my life I don't need
it
um I I I miss the old scary movies I am
going to watch black phone just because
uh Kelly said it's such a great movie
um
but once I started getting involved in
the messy lives of my neighbors and
community members and family members
friends
man I didn't need any more I didn't need
any more scary at any more horror
anymore whatever no judgment on anybody
who does man because I dude I've been
there I love them love love them but
once I started actively putting both
feet into my community I got plenty of
plenty of uh scary moments and hard
moments intense moments right
um in the world's intense and scary
place right now so let's follow Jenna's
yeah let's just uh watch some happy
stuff all right we'll be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right we are back and thank you for
joining us today I hope you have a safe
and fun Halloween
I can't wait till Halloween because I'm
gonna get off the rails and eat my body
weight and gummy candy and so I hope you
I hope you have have taken care of
yourself up until this moment so you can
get off the rails too
um today's song of the day comes from my
favorite Halloween movie ever ever I saw
this on a date with my good friend
Melissa back when I was a freshman in
high school and I love the movie The
Nightmare Before Christmas I love it
love it love it love it
um
and so the song the one of the greatest
soundtracks of all time by Danny Elfman
um the song is called This is Halloween
and the lyrics go like this boys and
girls of every age wouldn't you like to
see something strange come with us and
you will see this our town of Halloween
this is Halloween pumpkin scream in the
dead of night this is Halloween everyone
makes this everybody make a scene trick
or treat till our neighbor's gonna die
of fright it's our town everybody scream
of Halloween
hey I love y'all be safe I'll see you
soon
[Music]